hola soy mariano rincón esguerra y hoy
vengo acompañada de amelia quien me ha
estado conmigo todos estos años de
aventuras en la policía nacional
comencemos desde hace muchos años y todo
el gran privilegio de nacer en la
familia más hermosa del mundo en la
policía nacional de colombia
la primera persona en la que vi después
de la cara del médico cuando nací fue un
policía mi papá y ahí comenzó la gran
aventura de mi vida y creo que también
comenzó la de él
quieren saber quién me hace sentir la
niña más orgullosa del mundo caminar de
la manera mi papito cuando está
uniformado es como si caminara de la
mano de un superhéroe o como si
tuviéramos la posibilidad de salvar al
mundo es que piensen imaginen lo por un
instante el caminando por un centro
comercial o entrar al colegio que la
gente se te quede mirando y diga guau
miren hallaba spider-man dejando su hija
al colegio dejó de salvar al mundo por
un instante para cumplir como padre
suena raro verdad pero así lo siento yo
cuando todo estaba en la barriguita de
mi mamita mi papá trabajaba cuidando las
calles de bogotá un trabajo que ocupaba
gran parte de su tiempo se iba muy
temprano en las mañanas y regresaba muy
tarde en las noches
su trabajo era muy importante porque
protegía a las personas de las cosas
malas que podrían afectar su paz y su
tranquilidad
cuando regresaba a casa mi mitad ya
estaba dormida pero mi papá el policía
sacaba tiempo para mí sin importar su
cansancio le destapó la barriguita
mismamente y me leí un cuento y su
influenciado mucho mi vida ya que en
estos momentos me encanta leer y cómo no
sentirme orgullosa de este hombre que
representa todos los papitos de una
institución un papito que transforma la
cantidad de tiempo en calidad de tiempo
que casi nunca está en casa con la
mayoría de mis cumpleaños no puede estar
conmigo que las noches de navidad o año
nuevo mientras todos estamos celebrando
él está cuidando las calles para que
nadan en nuestra celebración pero sobre
todo un papito que representa los
valores más hermosos de un ser humano la
honestidad la disciplina el trabajo
negado y lo más importante para mí un
hombre que no es indiferente del dolor
de los demás
el año pasado pero en la mención de
honor en mi colegio y me gané la beca y
papá tampoco puede estar conmigo para
acompañarme pero mi logro se lo dedique
a él porque se el resultado de su
ejemplo y su dedicación mi mamita y yo
nos sentimos muy orgullosos de él porque
no todas las familias pueden ser el
resultado del amor de un superhéroe y
una súper mamá
mi vida como hija de un policía está
llena de aventuras y experiencias que no
podría vivir cualquiera
gracias a su trabajo ya todos los
traslados en los que le hemos acompañado
he podido conocer diferentes culturas de
mi país grupos indígenas diferentes
tipos de comida tengo amiguitos en
muchas partes del país que les he
contado el importante trabajo que tiene
mi papito y creo que también les he
transmitido mi orgullo mis 11 años no se
pasaban de patrullas de policía
uniformes ceremonias botas jefes
jefecitos jefes dotes y ahora comprendo
que todo lo que hacen es para mejorar y
servirle a mi país
la diferencia al despertar de las
mañanas de otros niños que lo hacen con
el canto de un gallo o un despertador
convencional mis despertares estuvieron
invadidos por una trompeta que casi
siempre sentí como si la estuvieran
tocando en la sala de mi casa cuando
vivíamos en el espinal tolima un
pueblito muy caliente y lleno de
zancudos pero para mí el pueblo más
hermoso del mundo mi casa queda junto a
la guardia entra a la escuela y ahí
todas las mañanas está un estudiante
ensayando para ser el trompetista de las
ceremonias y en la banda
todas las mañanas cuando escuchamos la
trompeta mi mente y yo sabíamos que
nuestro día o iniciar todos mis
recuerdos están pintados con verde oliva
con verde esperanza con verde en mi papá
el policía y cada vez que pienso en eso
mi corazón palpita más fuerte las manos
me sudan me sale una sonrisita pícara y
creo que hasta mis pupilas toman forma
de corazón es que así me imagina
sentirse enamorada mis mejillas se ponen
más son rosadas y yo ay qué hermoso son
todos pues me imagino no cuando veo
alguien con el mismo uniforme con la
misma dedicación y con la misma entrega
cuando mi papito en esta pienso qué
afortunada soy soy la hija de la policía
nacional y yo me siento orgullosísima de
todos
pues bien esta ha sido mi historia
cargada de ausencias de traslados de
cambios inesperados de colegio de
adaptarme a muchas culturas de mi país
de rezarle todas las noches a diosito
para que proteja mi papito pero sobre
todo una historia cargada de orgullo por
ser la hija de un policía de color
[Aplausos]